alors frédéric beigbeder vous êtes le
patron du cac à ça veut dire quoi
caucase ce président à vie président a
vu ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire rien
c'est le nom le plus bête qu'on ait
réussi à trouver je viens trouve kaka ça
déplaît à la foire bourgeois un branchés
aux hambourgeois parce que c'est un
le stupide et l'autre en chine c'est un
mollet il a été fondé en initial ne
signifie pas quelque chose de frais la
terrase harper s'adonne kaka ça veut
dire club des analphabètes comme et
attachant donc
tout à fait mais attachant je me trouve
attachant oui pour atteindre plus de
celui ci gratuit cela plaît avec des
glaçons de six batteries s'est effondré
auquel avaient toutefois aujourd'hui ces
choses là enfin yaya 3 en effet 85 et le
but de l'association c'est quoi
alors là naître une dissidence dans les
bcbg comment vous expliquez pour faire
la fête pour rigoler pour vivre au
présent
jeter des confettis
pardonnez moi c'est pour s'amuser entre
bcbg quoi un du tout non non non c'est
pour se déguiser et pour donner un
esprit constructif et un peu premier de
juin à la fête vous avez depuis des
années on en est revenu des fêtes ou
oppose ouais mais des
debbie ses habits bizarre nous nous
sommes au premier degré c'est à dire ce
que nous ne cherchons pas à plaire à
épater les gens ce choix nous amuser
c'est tout mais non c'est tout et je
bois par l'oreille pour le raid est une
erreur que j'assume
je bois parlera avec une erreur c'est
pas terrible c'est une erreur je bois à
la santé des pauvres je crois que
de tous les bords conçois qu'on soit
riche ou moins riches on a toujours eu
de rigoler et les riches s'ennuie bon
ben il faut bien qu'ils trouvent une
solution à ça c'est un truc pour amuser
les riches quoi c'est une oeuvre de
bienfaisance pour les riches bien sûr
ton but de cette cache il est aussi pas
d'amuser les riches les combien de
membres de quatre cents 400 oui oui 200
filles de son make way les filles sont
recrutés sur leur physique et les
mairies sont sur leur qi le plus bas
possible
on peut y rentrer mais bon elle est
bonne celle là on peut y rentrer et
comment pas du tout c'est à dire que
pour y rentrer faut payer le moins cher
possible non il faut être déguisé je
croise et des bals costumés vous savez
tous les mois dans une boîte différents
un bal costumé donc il faut être costume
est aussi un passant est habillé en
cow-boy à la soirée de demain soir eh
bien il rentrera
s'il est habillé en fille encore un mois
et ces soirées ont lieu au en général
aubin partout il y en a eu ici on a eu
au palace irait
chez régine chez castel oui il y en a eu
partout c'est quoi les thèmes les plus
drôles les soirées qui ont été les plus
réussis et qu'elle met plus drôle la
soirée la mieux c'était barry lyndon au
palace une soirée 18e avec dîner qui
s'est terminée en pugilat à coups de
cailloux
ouais
qui ont volé alors qu'elle avait été
bien cuit pour y avait une bataille de
tarte à la crème une joute sur le lac du
bois de boulogne déguisé aux vikings
j'étais le roi en général on s'en tire
avec quand même dans les vingt mille
francs de dégâts je préférerais
d'ailleurs que cette phrase ne passe pas
trop à l'antenne à cause des
propositions que j'en sois en ce moment
les divers établissements qui paye
justement la question écoutez fallait
qu'elle président il a droit à la parole
je représente que moi mais je crois que
j'ai trouvé dit que le but est de
s'amuser pas du tout le but ultime est
redit avec des buts les plus ringards
possible purcell moi je m'ennuie à
chaque fois merci fait les rues en bois
beaucoup kakal j'ai des chances et des
chances qu'on boive pas mal l'important
succès tu sais qui et des jolies filles
la bonne musique un conte boivent
après il ya des sadia trop compliqué
parce qu'un truc à la mode en france de
france non ça veut dire quoi les
français je passe des français mais moi
j'aime défense en attendant la bostella
baril vaut pas celle ci voulait on se
défonce dans la mesure où quand on est
allongé par terre et 80 personnes debout
sur vous finalement c'est dans un rail
d'héroïne ça n'est pas des années
pas tellement règle 2 non j'ai une
héroïne s'il veut des khalifa ça y va
sur le zizi avec ça y va sur le zizi je
crois que l'anp dans la mesure où le
sexe est une drogue alors la drogue je
dirais dit leur merci du leur camp mais
yvan bastel
c'est pas l'avenir du cacao
de quelqu'un de vis au présent ouais
je crois que en a trop parlé de l'avenir
dans un monde comme le nôtre il faut
essayer de s'amuser essayer de prendre
du bonheur au moment où on entend
d'ailleurs moi en ce moment vous voyez
je connais pas mon temps je suis là je
paye absolument pas ce whisky dont
vraiment tout va très très bien obligé a
dit que rien à voir le caca sur le wifi
gratuit merci infiniment
c'est le retour de blues aurait quoi ce
sens du changement d'horaire j'ai pas
entendu dire que les besoins doré avait
disparu de la scène et pour être sûr de
ne rien rater de 1h10 tube abonnez vous
il m'était impossible ou